want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only tony robbins
people think they have to know how i
called the tyranny of how
like you get all excited i'm gonna do
this and then your brain goes i've never
done it before oh my god what did i say
i don't know how to do this
and they tend to focus on how to do it
and when you start with how you're
screwed
like martin luther king had no idea how
when he did his i have a dream speech in
fact his wife was the one that pushed
him because he was uncertain right you
know the real history it's pretty
interesting but the bottom line is he
gets up there and he gives his vision of
how it can be done he talked about what
needs to happen and why
if you can figure out what you want and
why you want it and you get strong
enough reasons reasons that'll drive you
late at night it'll get you up early in
the morning and the reasons are
different some people do it for nitty
gritty reasons jim rohn used to say
because you know some guy told him he
borrowed money from this finance company
i forget the name of hfc finance where
the hell it was
and
you know he hadn't been back since he
borrowed the money you know so they're
calling him in those days they can
harass you in ways they can't today
right they would call him show up and
embarrass him in front of his neighbors
and so jim rohn his first real chunk of
money he told me he made because it's
like he set this goal it was his nitty
gritty reason his reason to get rich was
so we could go down and pay this thing
off and he said he went to the bank and
got it all in cash and in small bills
and he bolted into this little hfc you
know finance place and the guy who
borrowed the money was the fourth best
back and he said i walked up there i
opened i opened up this brief and i
dumped all the money all over his desk
and small bills and i said count it it's
all there i will never be back he said
he was startled because i hadn't been
there since i borrowed the money right
but he did it for nitty gritty but some
people do it for their kid
some people will do it like we almost
all do it for something more than
ourselves some people do it because they
like winning
right i know that about you
right it's like i like winning i like
being the best at what i do so i'm not
going to settle for less than that why
would i
right so you got to find your reasons
but if you know what you want and you
get a big enough why now you'll figure
out how to do it but if you start with
how
you know the small brain the fear brain
goes so [ __ ] i don't know what they
don't know where to go i don't know what
to do 90 percent of time either i know
what and why and then i try something
doesn't work i try something else or hit
something else now i speed it up
by learning from the best
so that's why you know money mastery
game is a perfect example
my companies you know at the time were
100 million dollar companies i had one
500 million dollar company
now we're doing seven billion
i took what i learned from these guys i
applied it not only am i investing i
applied it to my own businesses why do i
reinvent the wheel when i just learn
from the best on earth i mean somebody's
that good can tell you that little two
millimeter thing that changes everything
so my life is really about learn from
the best but i don't start with the how
i start with the what and the why and i
think that's the mistake most people
make one of the things you have to
understand about life is
everything changes and everything ends
and that kind of sounds heavy on the
front end but it's a truth if everything
changes and everything ends number one
it should make you appreciate what you
have right now
and then my view is what's next is
always better
if i make it so it's my job to make it
so and so i think you know for me
i look at it and say
you know when you said uh genius is a
young man's game i think it's total
um i think
passion is the genesis of genius
if you've got enough passion you're
gonna find answers nobody else does but
most people run out of fuel meaning they
get tired they get exhausted they get
burned out they get
uh you know the law familiarity they're
around something so much they take it a
little bit for granted and i've managed
to see something in myself
that i've found in every great leader
that i've ever respected and that is
i i value intelligence immensely but i
know really smart people can't fight
their way out of a paper bag
pragmatically right i'm sure you do too
what i see is the one common denominator
of people that are successful over a
lifetime is the sustained hunger
hunger
is the number one factor we are made to
grow if we don't grow it doesn't matter
how much money you make doesn't how many
people gave you academy awards stars on
your chart i mean i get the phone calls
from all these people who you would
think have the greatest life in the
world and then they're calling me
because it's not so great because they
haven't mastered the inner world they're
good at the outer world
but this one this one hasn't been given
enough time or energy they've been so
focused out here and they've done so
well out here not so well in here this
is the one you want to do well on do
well here you can master the outside
world too you can handle anything so for
me it really comes down to looking at it
and saying okay
if you and i are going to have an
extraordinary level of fulfillment
what's going to make me grow because
that's what's going to make me proud and
to grow you've got to face challenges
and i think the biggest problem most
people have
is the biggest problem they have is they
think they shouldn't have problems you
know it's like problems are a sign of
life problems with what make you grow
now you know i'd rather call it a
challenge i'd rather look as a challenge
and take it on as a challenge but you
and i both know i mean i have grown so
much in the last 24 months taking 105
companies some of which were literally
shut down for you know 12 months
keeping them alive not letting go on my
employees figure a way to turn around
figuring out adapt i mean i've developed
more skill and ability to help other
people because i had to manage my own
state unbelievably so i help other
people manage their state so without the
challenge would i grow so much probably
not your happiness will never last as
long as it's got expectation behind it
don't get me wrong i have businesses i
run them we manage them but i know that
people are going to screw up or my idea
script is different than i think they
should be and sometimes their script
will turn into something even better
right i got to give it room so what i
did was i began to realize
i made the decision it's the most
important decision i believe of your
life that i'm not going to suffer
anymore life's too short to suffer and
i'm going to live in a beautiful state
every day and the way i do it is i catch
myself when i start to get that sense of
stress
i let it go and i see the idea go by so
your thoughts
thoughts about this person messing up
your business or not following through
if i was in a room with ten thousand
people i guarantee you sixty seventy
percent of the business owners have the
same thoughts at times right i ask
people all the time tell me your most
stressful thought oh i'm worried about
my children this may happen how many
people have had that thought everybody i
might not make it financially well how
many times about everybody my point is
it's not your thought
it's the mind not your mind when you
think it's your mind you identify with
it and it's you can't separate from
yourself
but when you realize
these thoughts been around for millions
of years
and i'm just thinking the same thought
that so many people thought before like
how many people have ever thought i'm
gonna kill the son of a [ __ ] now you
didn't do it because you didn't believe
you're really going to kill them but you
felt it you said it you were there right
so we all have thoughts
it's only the stressful thoughts we
believe that mess us up so what i try to
show people is if you can start to
realize
these thoughts have been around for
millions of years if i told you a
million years you know a thousand a
hundred years ago that we're gonna go to
the moon and back you called me a
lunatic a crazy if i said a hundred
years ago you're gonna have a little box
like this it'll fit in your pocket
and you can click on it and you can see
what the weather is anyplace you can
click on it and see a live person on the
other side of the earth and talk to them
by looking this box and the way it works
is invisible waves are traveling around
the earth and it pulls invisible waves
in the box you go like read between the
lines there's no way you dumb idiots
so what i want you to realize those
thoughts are invisible ways
when you turn on tv it takes invisible
waves and depending on the channel
you're going to see a love story or an
adventure or a drama
or a comedy or a horror
the way you use your body determines
which of those thought waves come
through you one moment you're pissed off
the next moment somebody makes you laugh
you change your body you change the
channel you change what comes through
you so what i've tried to do in this
area beautiful state is simple yeah
first identify where you're suffering
what's your favorite flavor are you a
worrier are you a pissed off person
what is it you do
second of all decide you're going to
kill that monster while it's little
you're not going to wait till it's
godzilla taking the city you're going to
break the pattern you start to feel the
stress you see it as thoughts going by
and then you focus on something to
appreciate enjoy or love appreciation
love enjoy destroy suffering you can't
be grateful and angry simultaneously
it's possible you can't be worried and
fearful and grateful simultaneously so i
tell people gratitude is one of the
emotions to cultivate that'll destroy
the suffering and that's what we teach
people to do victor frankel was a
um viennese uh jewish uh man who got
locked up in world war ii and watched
his family be slayed in front of him in
the nazi concentration camp but he
stayed alive by studying what made
certain people live because you'd lose
the will there there was it was it was
a holy unholy place would be the nicest
way of describing inhuman
and
he said that what he noticed was that
the people that had a reason they could
find reason even in their suffering like
they're going to make it through this so
they could tell the story so it could
never happen again you know the famous
never again jewish phrase he said those
people found a way to survive the ones
that gave up and didn't have a
compelling future and i think that's
what's missing right now by the way for
so many people in middle clovid they see
no compelling future and that's why
they're over doing drugs or alcohol
because it's like i'm out of control but
i learned so much from him and so much
from the book that no one can take they
can take your money they can imprison
you can do everything but they can't
take away your will your will to find
meaning in your life if you want a great
jump in the quality of your life an
extraordinary jump in the quality of
your life
you got to set yourself up to win
you got to set yourself up with a
process that allows you to consistently
grow consistently enjoy your life and
consistently produce the results that
you're really after and i don't care
what area of life you want to change
coaching is one of the most valuable
tools in the world now when i started my
career there was no coaching industry i
helped to father that interesting
industry almost 35 years ago and it's
kind of interesting when i first started
out if somebody would have said oh one
of the best ways you can help an
executive perform at a higher level is
get them a personal coach i mean people
would have laughed at you but today it's
a multi-billion dollar industry because
seventy percent of the fortune 500 now
say in a recent study if you want to
find the top three ways to improve
performance of an executive one of those
is personal coaching
but again when i began you know i'll
tell you kind of the history of how this
came about i was a young man who was
always looking for answers i wanted to
change my own life initially physically
mentally emotionally and financially but
as soon as i got answers
i always was coaching other people when
i was you know in high school i was mr
solution if you had a problem i had the
solution especially if you're a girl
because i was more motivated and i want
to really help you know but really at
that time i would feed my mind i didn't
have a lot of coaches to come after i
fed my mind with books i read a book a
day my goal is read a book every single
day that's about personal development
improvement psychology physiology
something that could help you improve
your life and when people needed help i
had the answer and i got hooked on
having those answers so i kind of
started that coaching at that stage
where i coached myself and people saw
results and those results made people
ask me what to do and that's how i got
involved in it you hear this where focus
goes energy flows
most people are focused on what they're
afraid of and so more fear comes their
way and it's easy because we all have a
2 million year old brain that's designed
to look for what's wrong to protect so
we protect ourselves to fight it or to
run for it or to freeze right that's the
way our old brain is wired it's a two
million year old brain but that brain is
never going to make you happy you have
to learn to take control of your focus
and if you focus on oh my god it's never
going to work or you listen to somebody
who tells you oh you know coven's going
to be here forever we're never going to
have any freedom again and you focus on
that you can get really depressed as
most people have we've had 100 000
people overdose on drugs we have more
depression and more people in a suicidal
mode than we've ever seen in the last
two years because people need a
compelling future you can deal with a
tough today if you got a compelling
tomorrow and so what i help people do is
design that but once you change your
focus you'll change how you feel focus
and feeling go together momentum is
everything right the hardest part in
life is creating momentum so when that
all happened you know i had built
something of momentum over you know 40
years literally at that point
around the world and you know what do
you do all of a sudden when you know
suddenly they say you can't do an event
with more than 10 people and you've got
15 000 people scheduled to take over the
stadium
and you know you know what i did i went
we're going to vegas they're never going
to shut down vegas right but then they
shut down vegas i was like i know i'm
going to rent a church a mega church
from a buddy of mine in houston 15 000
people they're not going to keep costco
open and shut down the church they kept
costco up and shut down the church so i
got to the point where it's like what do
you do and when you think there's
nothing you can do that's when you can
do something when you think i don't know
what to do that's when you know what to
do if you just push yourself and so i
was like i pulled my team together i saw
a guy do like a webinar with 252 inch
screens and i said i'll kill myself
first i said i got to create an
experience for people they need it
desperately wherever they are in the
world so literally i pulled out a tape
recorder's like okay here's what we're
going to do we're going to do 20 foot
high led screens 50 feet wide highest
resolution in the world 0.67 150 you
know 50 degree 180 degrees around me
around the back i'm going to call my
buddy eric yawn i'm going to see if
zoomed we can expand in from the little
thousand to 20 thousand or thirty
thousand i'm gonna hire a firm to create
an app so they can shake it so it sends
a signal and you can hear reality of
people clapping because the more shake
it the louder it gets and i just started
creating the whole thing an hour there
someone's done my cfo says uh
tony um you know after he saw all the
numbers he was over 20 million bucks
what time we're doing he's like tony
should we rent some of this first
and i said to him i said listen of all
first of all you can't i said go do your
best not what i'm looking for i said
second of all this is going to be this
way for a while yeah and we're going to
use this to help more people and that
you know when things go back to normal
we get to go do that too and i just did
a date with destiny where i had you know
10 000 people from 97 countries and then
i had 500 people in front of me because
i built the studio so that there's 40
foot high ceilings so i could literally
lift the 20-foot screen and so now i
have a hybrid event people don't want to
come personally i'm there people that
want to be in the middle of the night in
some other country are able to
participate but all that comes from just
taking action and momentum yeah if you
build momentum you can accomplish
anything you've seen it in sports you
see a team that's dominating and then
somebody steals the ball and the
momentum changes yeah your job right now
is great momentum and that's why i'm
building this challenge is basically to
say to you let's do a breakthrough for
you right now so you know it's real
let's get you get a real result let's
get you to shift yourself physically and
mentally emotionally so you can build
that momentum because it takes so much
energy to rock it out of the atmosphere
takes very little to get out of the
solar system so that momentum i think is
critical you mentioned you reach out to
someone you'll text someone you'll send
a voice note or a video message or maybe
you're calling them or just saying hi to
them and telling them you're
acknowledging something that they're
doing well that you appreciate
i don't think that many people do this
why is this so important
for you personally and why do you think
this would help so many people get out
of themselves and overcome anxiety and
stress if they did this even a couple of
times a week i know you do this every
day but
just a couple texts a week why was this
so valuable for people well number one i
love people so i love to sincerely if
you just call someone to make a
compliment and it's not sincere anybody
can feel that i don't do that you know
it's like i i pride myself on finding
the goodness in people or the skill sets
in people and i also know that what is
acknowledged tends to grow so from
standpoint of that i want them to feel
that feeling of being appreciated i want
them to know i see what's happening
behind the camera so to speak you know
it's like
that's what matters it's not how
everybody else sees you it's how you
really are and then it also deepens
every relationship you have when you
sincerely acknowledge somebody and you
notice something other people don't
notice and so it deepens the connection
and to me
quality of life is the quality of two
things your emotions and your
relationships and you know if my
emotions are terrible my relationships
are going to be terrible but if i have
great emotions and i can extend that out
to help other people then it just makes
me feel more alive so i i do it for me
and them it's it's a virtuous cycle i
believe in energy i believe in
inspiration because inspired in spirit
the opposite of that is kind of dead
right so i certainly i believe in being
inspired but i'm a strategist at my best
you know you're if you're inspired and
you run east looking for a sunset i
don't give a damn how enthusiastic you
are how positive you are it's not going
to happen so i'm a strategist first but
i really do believe that people have got
to look at their life and say
as much as i want great strategy i need
a great philosophy of my life that's
going to make me fulfilled if you're
fulfilled like you said you mentioned
earlier if you were with your friends
and you guys weren't succeeding but
you're having a damn good time with this
camaraderie
it's still worthwhile and you find a way
to succeed eventually but what the hell
is success it's hitting an expectation
and i always tell people man trade your
expectations for appreciation it's a
whole new world instantly if you can
appreciate this moment if you can't find
ecstasy in this moment in a conversation
with a friend and looking in your wife's
eyes being with your children going on a
run
if you can't find xe now i'm here to
tell you
more money
more people more love more business more
anything is not going to give you more
access if you can't do it here now
you're not going to do it there when you
got more so why not do it now and have a
rich life right now i tell people
money that's one thing like having
financial abundance there's skills
that's a science but wealth it's a
decision it's like you can be wealthy
right now i live in fiji a good portion
of time there are these villagers there
they're the richest people to know
they're happy they laugh they love they
don't give a damn about the economics
other people say they're poor when i
first went there i was trying to do
things for them like what are you
talking about i'm so happy wealthy
people come over from the united states
and they go travel around and try to
figure out what to do and they're going
to spend nine months you know years to
do this and this and this so they can
finally sit down and be happy and the
jean guy goes why don't you sit on the
beach right now dude experience it why
spend the nine years
why not have it now that's my invitation
i constantly believe you got to feed
your mind and and challenge your body
because the mind body works together you
know what stops people as we said is
fear well fear is physical you feel your
throat your gut but if you do something
really physically strong on a regular
basis you develop a new emotional habit
and that emotional habit will get you to
follow through and do things differently
that people won't do it's really not
that complex there are a few habits in
your life that truly could change your
whole life i start every single day with
this process called priming training my
brain to be in a peak state because we
get primed all the time you know people
aren't aware of it but there was a study
that was done not long ago where they
took some people 100 actors they walked
up to 100 people in the park and they
rehearsed doing the same thing every
time they reach in their pocket to get
their phone and they or they hand the
person a cup of coffee and then they
reach in their pocket looking and say
would you hold this to me for a second
to a full stranger they grab their phone
look at it type it they take it back
well thank you so much
the same for everybody but then they
come back 30 minutes later with somebody
with uh and the only difference by the
way is 50 of them have iced coffee 50 of
them have hot coffee got it now a person
comes by 30 minutes later with a
clipboard gives him 20 and said if
you'll give me literally a minute half
of your time to read this three
paragraph story and answer these two
questions this is yours 9 8 10 people
take the 20 bucks and do it they read
the story same story for everybody
but half the people when they ask them
the main character how would you
describe the qualities of the main
character the character traits the ones
that got iced coffee all say the person
was cold and uncaring eighty-one percent
say that come on hot coffee eighty
percent or one percent difference say
the person is warm and genuine and the
only difference is 30 minutes earlier
somebody primed them see you think it's
your thoughts much of your thoughts have
been primed by the environment by the
media by what you read to by your family
by your friends by your culture by your
background so what i do every day is i
prime myself for what i want rather than
letting the environment control me
emotion is it if we get the right
emotion we can get ourselves to do
anything we can get through it if you're
creative enough playful enough fun
enough can you get through to anybody
yes or no
if you don't have the money but you're
creatively determined enough you find
the way so this is the ultimate resource
but this is not the story that people
tell us
right the story people tell us is a
bunch of different stories they tell us
we don't have the resources but
ultimately if you take a look here flip
it up if you would
they say what all the reasons they have
in common we said that next one please
he's broken my pattern
[Laughter]
but i appreciated the energy i'll tell
you that
what determines your resources we've
said decision-shaped destiny which is my
focus here if decisions shape destiny
what determines it is three decisions
what are you going to focus on right now
you have to decide what you're going to
focus on in this second consciously or
unconsciously the minute you decide to
focus on something got to give it a
meaning
and whatever that meaning is produces
emotion is this the end or the beginning
is god punishing me or rewarding me or
is this the role of the dice
an emotion then creates what we're going
to do or the action so think about your
own life the decisions that have shaped
your destiny and that sounds really
heavy but in the last 5 or 10 years 15
years have been some decisions you've
made that you made a different decision
your life would be completely different
how many can think of one honestly
better or worse say aye
so the bottom line is maybe it was where
to go to work and you met the love of
your life there maybe it was a career
decision i know the google geniuses i
saw here i mean i understand that their
decision was to sell their technology at
first what if they made that decision
versus to build their own culture how
would the world be different how would
their lives be different their impact
the history of our world is these
decisions when a woman stands up and
says no i won't go to the back of the
bus
she didn't just affect her life that
decision shaped our culture or someone
standing in front of a tank or being in
a position like lance armstrong and
someone says to you you've got
testicular cancer that's pretty tough
for any male especially if you ride a
bike
you got in your brain you got in your
lungs but what was his decision of what
to focus on different than most people
what did it mean it wasn't the end it
was the beginning what are they going to
do he goes off and wins seven
championships he never wants once before
the cancer because he got emotional
fitness
psychological strength
that's the difference in human beings
that i've seen of the three million have
been around because that's about my lab
i've had three million people
from 80 different countries that i've
had a chance to interact with over the
last 29 years and after a while patterns
become obvious you see that south
america and africa maybe connect in a
certain way right other people say oh
that sounds ridiculous it's simple so
what shape lance what shapes you two
invisible forces very quickly
one state
we all have had times if you had a time
you did something and after you did it
you thought to yourself i can't believe
i said that i can't believe i did that
that was so stupid who's been there say
aye
have you ever done something after you
do you go
that was me
right it wasn't your ability it was your
state i should be able to change that
quickly but what i want to finish with
quickly here is
your model of the world is what shapes
you long term
your model of the world is the filter
that's what's shaping us that's what
makes people make decisions we want to
influence somebody we got to know what
already influences them and it's made up
of three parts i believe first what's
your target what are you after which i
believe it's not your desires you can
get your desires to goals how many of
you forgot a goal desire and thought is
this all there is how many been there
say i
so it's needs we have i believe there
are six human needs second
once you know what the target that's
driving you is and then you uncover it
for the truth you don't form it you
uncover it then you find out what your
map what's the belief systems that are
telling you how to get those needs some
people think the way to get those needs
is destroy the world some people have to
build something create something love
someone fundamentally the most basic
thing you got to do especially at a time
like covet is you got to every day have
a couple of simple practices one of
those is every day you got to feed your
mind and when i say fiji miami
consciously seek out something that's
going to give you new insight new
inspiration new way of looking things
because otherwise today the news follows
you right it's in your pocket and the
news people are good people but they're
doing their job what's their job make as
much profit as possible how do you get
the most profit get the most people to
watch i get the most people to watch
fear
if it you know if it if it bleeds it
leads is the phrase they use in
journalism right and we've seen so much
fear built up now that most people have
lost their faith and you can't lose it
fortunately it's just a muscle that
needs to be regained but you have to
fill your mind you have to pursue it
great ideas are not going to interrupt
you they have to be pursued and the good
news is today if you get away from just
the traditional news you can do a lot of
podcasts like boss vapes you can go to
different locations you can get another
perspective and you can feed your mind
but if you don't feed your mind my
original teacher was a guy named jim
rohn
and he used to say tony i got a question
for you
he said what if
your worst enemy puts sugar in your
coffee what's going to happen to you
when you drink that coffee is that
you're going to have sweet coffee he
said you know what if your family member
your friend your love by accident drops
one drop of strychnine what's going to
happen when you drink that coffee you're
going to be dead he goes that's right
life is sugar and strychnine so watch
your coffee like every day you got to
stand guard at the door of your mind
especially at times like this when
there's so much fear just to
entrepreneurs in general
uh and you're an entrepreneur wildly
successful entrepreneur and uh you work
with and are friends with many many of
the top entrepreneurs in the world what
are a few of the common attributes of
the super successful entrepreneurs that
you've seen there might not be the
obvious ones that yeah you know come to
mind well gosh you know i'll give one
example because just talking to
yesterday mark benny offers a dear
friend of mine and he runs a company
called salesforce.com he found it mark
went to my unleash the power with an
event about 15 years ago he went to it
three times you know you know
repetitions the mother skill immersed
himself in it again a pro not gonna do
something average comes up to me and
introduced himself and says tony he said
you've changed my life i'm working for
oracle i'm leaving i'm starting this
company salesforce.com we're going to
change the business world on every case
we're going to do a hundred million
dollars in business i was teasing the
night he's gonna do seven billion this
year right and i've been on a 15-year
journey with them you know what what do
they have in common they have a sense of
something they want to serve greater
than themselves you know the only
challenge sometimes in network marketing
and i think what gives it a bad
reputation for some people is you get
people in there that really act like
they're doing it for something larger
than themselves but it really is only
them now there's nothing wrong with you
wanting to profit and be successful but
motive does matter and the most
successful entrepreneurs have a motive
that includes themselves but they want
to do something that's going to change
the world make the world different it's
like you know when you're trying to meet
your own needs you get a certain level
of insight if you're trying to meet the
needs of a family your family you get a
different level of insight because life
supports whatever supports more of life
more people if you're trying to support
your community differently if you're
trying to you know have an impact on the
world it's even larger and i found in
network marketing you find a few
missionaries that are like those other
entrepreneurs that it really is their
mission they'd honestly do it for free
and you know they want to make money and
they do make money but if you're only
doing it for the money the unfortunate
part is um people sense that and then
they feel like it's just a transaction
as opposed to an experience of added
value it's only one way on earth
to really become wealthy and that is do
more for others than anybody else is
doing three skills will make you
successful no matter how long you live
no matter what changes in society skill
number one
it's the ability to recognize patterns
you're really good at it you do it in
finance you do it in business you're not
just blowing your smoke that's why
you're successful because when you
recognize patterns it allows you to go
the second step which is use them
if you recognize financial patterns you
can do great things you recognize
patterns of business you can turn around
in your business you know that's what
i've been doing i have 105 companies now
we do seven billion dollars in business
and i have no business background but i
recognized the patterns and i studied
the billionaires that started with
nothing and said what did they do how
did they do it how'd they turn it around
so if you can recognize patterns and if
you can use them
you got a great advantage but then
gradually over time like
you know if you're going to play the
piano usually play other people's music
initially
and then there's a point where you come
through now you start creating patterns
and we start creating patterns that's
when you become a dominant force in
business and life in the marketplace and
with your children or anywhere else i
think this idea of loving yourself as a
cultural obsession has no basis in
reality
here's the challenge when you're born
what do you got to do to be loved
nothing because your mother's on drugs
natural dogs oxytocin so you look like a
lizard and she thinks you're beautiful
right you know you're fat you [ __ ] all
over you throw up and you're still
beautiful right for a while you're
unconditionally loved and thank god we
wouldn't have survived otherwise i'm so
i love women so much i have so much
respect for women even more so going
through birth again
no man will ever fully appreciate what a
woman does or what a baby demands of
mother if you're breastfeeding and the
energy and the no sleep i mean it's just
it's amazing what women do in our lives
but the point is
in the beginning you do nothing and then
the oxytocin wears off and suddenly you
do the same scream or yellow throw your
food now you get yelled at or hit or the
worst one of all you get ignored
and then fear enters your body and then
the rest of your life you're looking for
how can i get this unconditional love
and i remember in the beginning asking
myself because yeah i studied all
animals and what the level of dependency
they have and you know human beings have
the longest period of dependency for
survival of any creature other than
other primates whales will be dependent
for a year birds for a few weeks and
boom get your ass out there and fly you
know it's a different world we have this
long dependency it's just the nature of
how we are and i thought to myself so
why
why don't we just have unconditional
love all the time and i think my answer
is because then you never grow or give
anything to life you think everything is
about you
and unfortunately there are a large
population of kids that are raised in a
generation of parents that were
helicopter parents that thought
everything should be about the child and
they wonder why they're selfish today or
why they you know don't seem to have
great relationships where you got to be
with somebody else you got to put
somebody else out of you that's what
love is
love is putting somebody else ahead of
yourself
loving yourself
usually comes for most human beings by
starting to have a value and just
appreciating people not because of what
they do not because of what they have
just because you feel their essence
and it's easier to do that with somebody
you love than is with yourself but when
you start to with somebody else and
you're not judging you're truly loving
them then it's much more natural because
you're already doing the loving you're
not getting it from somewhere else
someone may say something look you a
certain way as a trigger but all love is
self-love
and i don't love myself if you've ever
been someone who felt loved you loved
yourself they didn't love you they said
something needed something with their
eyes and you use that as a trigger to
release love inside of you
but
loving yourself every moment all the
time is not the secret to success
having appreciation for yourself is
different than constantly loving now in
the bible it says love thy neighbor as
thyself so i think it's a worthy goal
and it's useful but most people are
obsessed with it and i think get on
about living a life that's meaningful
and you'll love yourself as long as you
focus on you
you're not going to love you
because the human brain is always
looking for what's wrong what to protect
what needs to be changed it's a survival
instinct and so it's looking for things
to fight or flight or try to freeze or
pretend or not there about yourself but
when you're in a bit of service when
you're trying to search something more
than yourself that's when the higher
part of your consciousness is there
that's when your heart is flowing and
when you're doing that you're not
thinking about you and therefore you
feel love and i can tell you my own
experience
i've i don't have to no one else have to
earn love with me but my strategy has
been i got to earn my own love right i
got to be worthy of my own love i don't
do that somebody else how do you do that
well by helping millions of people for
44 years now i'm finding the stage well
yeah i can love myself i'm not there i
enjoy myself or appreciate it but along
the way
i've always earned it now i don't think
that's necessarily healthy or not but i
like what it's done with me
if i know people that just think they're
god's gift to creation and they don't
add anybody to any other human being and
they're [ __ ] to be around they love
themself so i just i would challenge
that whole belief system i'd say it's
appreciating yourself
it's loving the people around you and
the more you can unconditionally love
others the more you'll unconditionally
love yourself but trying to start with
yourself when you're not doing with
others forget it it'll never happen i
really want people to know
everything
life is always happening for you not to
you if you believe it's happening to you
of course it is you know you look for
what's wrong what's wrong is always
available but if you train yourself to
look for what's right and you find it
you won't be the person sitting on the
curb crying or feeling sorry or drugging
yourself up you'll be like i'm going to
crush it and i'm going to find the good
in this it's not good on the surface but
it becomes good when you do something
with it so there's always a way but it
requires a different level of energy it
requires that you have something you
want to serve more than yourself because
you're only serving yourself you don't
get a lot of insight nothing wrong with
that but but you're trying to serve your
family you're serving more of life so
life gives you more serve a community
serve humanity i'm not talking virtual
signaling but i'm talking about you know
what's in your heart you get a different
level of insight and a different level
of energy so you got to find something
you care about more than yourself in the
middle of covid and you got to find a
way to retool yourself to move forward
because the opportunity is going to be
there winter's not forever
the the tide will shift and you want to
be ready or ideally take advantage of
even before the tide shifts
if you haven't made a decision about
what you're going to do in your life you
have actually made a decision it was a
decision in action where does that
decision take people
well i think uh it happens at different
stages of life it's not like you have to
have this one mission a lot of people
are paralyzed i don't know my purpose
well your purpose is to enjoy your life
to grow and to give like
everyone has different ways but we all
compare it sometimes is it enough is it
strong enough is it big enough what i
found in my life is do what's in front
of you with all your vigor all your
passion give the most you can focus on
giving not trying to receive and you'll
receive more than you could ever imagine
but the person is always trying to get
nobody wants to deal with that person
nobody wants to be around them the
secret to living is giving it's what
makes you feel alive because you're no
longer in scarcity you're no longer
trying to get and no one wants to be
around them but you want to be around
yourself in that state how do you get
out of it it's just a habit it's just
like let me find every day one person to
start my day that i can sincerely
compliment no bs find something great
about them or someone i could help who's
in a worse case than i am could be
something very little but when you get
in those habits then all of a sudden
life is you know like i like everyday my
whole thing before i came here before i
do anything is like god use me you know
it's like i want to be a blessing in the
life of anybody i meet in some way
sometimes that blessing is i can take a
picture for them and they're excited
sometimes i can do an intervention
sometimes i can buy them seminars
sometimes i can just love on them
sometimes asking a great question but if
we're all focused on being a blessing in
each other's lives then our life is
filled with blessings because we're
we're not trying to get
all the love you want from others
if you feel inside yourself you'll be
expressing it to others and every time
you express it you feel alive inside
otherwise people tell you they love you
all day long and you can go yeah yeah
they don't really love me you know i
know lots of celebrities who started out
wanting so much love so they become
successful and unique so they get all
this adoration and they don't like their
lives now because they don't think it's
sincere i said you know your focus is if
you're celebrity why don't you use your
platform to serve in some way outside
what you do not attack but surf if you
do that you're gonna have a rich life i
remember turning 40
and i was really really unhappy i was
like jesus i've not done enough i've not
helped enough people i know tens of
millions of people at that point already
all over the earth in a hundred plus
countries at that point but it was still
kind of stuck in my head so i would earn
the love by over delivering change
somebody's life like i don't get it
because somebody says oh i love you tony
i mean i appreciate that oh you're the
greatest it's got to be my standard my
standard's higher than their standard
for me right so when i get up and
someone's going to kill themself and
it's they're suicidal and boom turn
around they're no longer not going to
kill themselves but they're transformed
their life is there you know that's when
i go okay you know now we've hit the
center of what i'm made for now you know
i deserve to feel this euphoric feeling
within myself and appreciation and even
then i still know it's god coming
through me i don't have the delusion
it's just me
but
i think sometime after 40 i finally saw
the stupidity of it i accumulated enough
that i looked at life with fresh eyes
and i could say by the time i turned 60
a year ago i noticed it was interesting
because my birthday i didn't have an
ounce of it i was just like
you know how could i at this stage of my
life when i've had the privilege of
serving so many humans in so many
contexts you know from turning around
you know guys gonna kill themselves with
ptsd to helping kids turn around to
getting kids off cocaine or adults to
you know help people build multi-billion
dollar businesses from nothing and when
i've lived this long i can't go by
without hearing half a dozen stories a
day or dozen stories a day from people
telling me how something i did change
their life so it's not that i'm so smart
now it's just i've stacked it by the way
though stacking is the way you can do
things
most of us stack the negative
if you are really angry it's not usually
because it's just the moment
it's that it happened again you know
it's like if you've ever lost it or
overreacted to your kid or to a friend
or a business or even within yourself
it's because it happened again we hit
this one two three many point and then
our nervous system overreacts but what
i've learned is you can stack the good
and but for example if you're if you go
into a state of really strong anger for
more than five minutes your immune
system is suppressed between an hour and
a half to two hours that's a
physiological fact but no one had done
any study i started stacking good like
okay let me stack a dozen great memories
feel them see them experience them
and i thought this biochemical change
that didn't just last a half hour an
hour or 10 minutes it went on for a day
or two and so i think
i've learned to stack the good so just
having the experience is not enough you
got to stack the good to be able to
appreciate it but i i think just come
back to the main point here from my
perspective which could be completely
just my perspective so i want to point
that out
i think the more
you find
unconditional love for others the easier
it is to find in yourself
and i think the focus is serving and
loving and that's what will get you the
point where you start doing it but if
you want to speed it up stack all the
good you've done you'll feel great about
yourself when 911 happened and i'll
finish with this i was in hawaii
i was with 2 000 people from 45
countries we were translating four
languages simultaneously for a program
that i was conducting for a week
the night before was called emotional
mastery i got up had no plan for this
and i said
uh we had a list of fireworks i do crazy
fun stuff and then at the end i stopped
and i had this plan i was going to save
it i never do what i'm going to say and
all of a sudden i said when do people
really start to live
when they face death
and then what this whole thing about if
you were going to get off this island if
nine days from now you were gonna die
who would you call what would you say
what did you do
one woman well that night is when 911
happened one woman had come to the
seminar and when she came there she her
previous boyfriend had been kidnapped
and murdered
her friend her new boyfriend wanted to
marry her and she said no he said if you
leave and go to the hawaii thing it's
over with her she said it's over when i
finished that night she called him and
left a message true story at the top of
the world trade center where he worked
saying honey i love you i just want you
to know i want to marry it was stupid of
me
she was asleep because it was 3 a.m for
us when he called her back from the top
and said honey i can't tell you what
this means
he said
i don't know how to tell you this but
you give me the greatest gift because
i'm going to die
and she played the recording for us in
the room she was on larry king later and
he said you're probably wondering how on
earth this could happen to you twice and
he said all i can say to you is this
must be god's message to you honey from
now on every day give your all love your
all don't let anything ever stop you
there's so many things you know people's
relationships are complex right because
you're dealing with another species even
if you're gay in order to have a a
relationship you need opposite energies
max male and female energies even if
it's in the same gender and so
relationships are a huge source of
challenge for people because it's where
you get the greatest joy to get the
greatest pain um i think in business
most people get into business and we all
know the stats 50 of businesses are gone
the first year 96 are gone in ten years
four out of 100 make it that doesn't
mean they're profitable so there's
different issues that you deal with
there people's bodies because of the way
we have commercialized food makes almost
everybody but 70 percent of americans
are overweight i mean it's the fast
country in the history of the world and
the rest of the world's mirroring us so
i deal with so many different issues it
really depends on the person people come
to me
usually at extremes they're either the
best in the world or what they do and
they're doing well and they just
they're the best because they're always
looking for that little step that little
thing i can do that makes me better
better better and takes me to a
different destiny
or it's somebody facing a challenge and
you know their thing a financial
challenge a business challenge an
emotional challenge a relationship
challenge with their kids or they have a
birthday with a zero on it so they're
reevaluating their life so i i get
people who have found a hunger they're
hungry because it's not how they want it
or they're hungry because that's their
nature people are not hungry i don't
really deal with because
they pretty much accept where things are
and so and so
what i wish for them what i pray for
them is they find something to inspire
them more than themselves or the wagon
wheel comes down their rut you know they
can obtain that they start searching and
i don't care how smart you are strong or
how rich you are how famous you are
life is gonna humble you you know like
life's gonna take you to your knees the
real question is what are you gonna do
when that happens and so for me it's
really like what this challenge is about
it's like a comeback challenge the
greatest story again what is the
greatest story of mankind what's the
story we all love in books and movies
it's a comeback it's somebody gets taken
to their knees unfairly unjustly
whatever or their own ego takes them
there and then instead of giving up they
get up they get knocked down they get up
you get and then eventually they only
get up and they don't get to where they
were get them better than they were i
was in my early 20s and i developed this
incredible arsenal of tools a toolbox a
tool chest if you will
of the very best tools to create change
rapidly things that look like magic to
people where i could take somebody and i
would go on a radio show or a tv show
and i would challenge traditional
psychologists and psychiatrists and i'd
say give me your worst patient i don't
care if they have uncontrollable phobias
have them come see me i'll handle it in
one hour and i developed this idea that
i was the one hour the one-stop coach
the person that can help people make any
change and i built my career by actually
doing that i got on television and radio
and i took people with lifetime phobias
and turned them around these are all
just techniques and strategies that i
didn't develop i just kept looking for
the best and i kept synthesizing it and
bringing it forward so when i started
out here i was this guy helping people
lose 30 60 90 in some cases 200 pounds
or taking a guy that was barely
surviving financially and within a
couple years of this
counseling or coaching as i started to
call it really got him to turn his
business around and literally got him
financially independent
relationships that were falling apart
and i i learned the distinctions to help
couples change and so when you start
getting those types of results that are
that measurable people started giving me
attention and the media started to come
to me and then what they wanted to know
was this what are you
you know and i thought are you a guru i
said no no no no no i'm not that you're
mr motivator like no no i i'm certainly
believing people having an inspired life
and think about it inspiration is pretty
important if you're not inspired what is
inspired it means in spirit means
there's an energy in your life if you're
not inspired about your life what do you
have nothing but i'm really more about
strategy and they kept pushing me guru
motivator what are you you know and i
said well you know what i really am i'm
a coach
and i came up with that metaphor i mean
there's always been consultants in
business i wasn't talking about
businesses it was individuals
and i said i'm not a therapist you know
i said and i don't have a degree
people pay me because i produce
measurable results they pay me nothing
unless i do it that's how i set up my
career that's how i built my brand and i
said you know for me coaches are people
that not better than you are
a coach just has a different perspective
i mean even back in those days the best
athletes in the days the gretzky's the
michael jordans etc they all had a coach
still to this day the best half coaches
because the coach can see what you can't
see because you're in the force they're
outside of it
and i know as an athlete i was better
than some of my coaches but they made me
better so i said that's my job i'm a
coach because to be a coach is not
better they're they're a friend they're
they're an equal they're there for you
there's somebody who cares deeply about
your well-being but they're also
incredibly skilled to help guide you at
the moment you really need it
and so i started promoting this idea of
being a coach and
you know the sports metaphor helped some
people but the media didn't buy into it
very much but i was able to succeed
finally because i was able to keep
measuring these results i mean i would
go out and say i'll come see me for one
session i'll handle this problem or you
pay me nothing you can check it out for
60 days i still use that formula to this
day as many of you know with my products
and services so what was really
fascinating though was along the way i
was there's a point after years of
calling myself a coach and there's no
coaching industry nobody talking
themselves as coaches i remember at one
point i hit a point where i was about to
give it up and larry king even said to
me on on air one time he said you know
what is this you're you're a coach what
does that mean and i was trying to
explain peak before it's coaching and
strategy and so forth and
and right about that time suddenly
coaching became the term of art and
everybody was a coach therapist started
calling themselves coaches you know
financial planners became coaches it
just became the term of art so it's been
a fascinating journey watching that word
come in because what i did is i helped
build that term by making it based on
real results so when you have the
meaning that this is the beginning of
the relationship for this person's most
incredible thing and you will do what
for them what will you do
anything what if you're that way with
your client
what if you're that way with your
internal customers cause your partners
you go well if you have real sexual
problems with hr that would be the real
challenge
but if you commitment was the same when
you're in that place you do anything in
the beginning of relationship in the
beginning relationship if your partner
said would you take out the trash what
do you say take up the trash
happily
but after about seven days or seven
weeks or seven months or seven years or
seventy years one day someone said we
take out the trash what do i look like
your janitor
you go what happened to our passion i'll
give you a clue
if you want a relationship to last if
you think it's coming to the end do what
you did in the beginning and there won't
be an end
because when you think it's the
beginning you behave differently than
the end the meaning we associate to
things controls our entire lives
it's not that your mother or father died
that's giving you suffering
certainly that's painful
it's the meaning you think it shouldn't
have happened
and we take control of the meaning it's
the only thing we can control our lives
we can't control events how could you
not be inspired when you're seeing
people eat again when you're seeing
people be free when you're you know
you're providing surgeries for you know
100 kids last year that were blinded who
can now see so i get the juice from the
big things that i get the juice from the
individual things but it for me it's
about impact if you can have impact in
your life is meaningful your life life
isn't going to be happy every moment
but it can be meaningful every moment
you know and that's your job it's our
job to find a deeper meaning and i think
that meaning comes and the energy of
life comes when you're not just trying
to serve yourself i think unfortunately
for so many of us social media
and technology
has started to shape us instead of us
shaping it you know it's using us and
the way it's using us is it's making us
selfish i mean you see people like
banging on their phone like give it a
moment you know it's going to a
satellite give it a second jerk you know
or you turn around you see people like
they expect like everything to be given
to them the moment they push a button
and humans don't work that way well i
think today
you're i've looked at the best mentors
because today because of the web you can
follow someone you don't even know you
can link read what they write you can
read their blogs you can interact in
ways with them sometimes you can talk to
them and talk back on social media so we
have more choices today on that than
ever but i also try to find don't have
the belief that your mentor has to be
perfect because none of us are there's
no perfect human beings and even if you
are perfect someone also turned around
saying you're not perfect from their
perspective so what you really want to
do is just say let me find two or three
people that have answers that have
proven it by their life example not
because they can verbalize it how
people's lips move don't matter how do
their feet move for 10 or 20 years and
so i've always looked for people that
were not only successful in the exterior
world but they're really happy and that
they're contributing to society in a
meaningful way because those are the
people that are most fulfilled and so i
think today you have to get clear what
do you want and then go looking and it's
not hard to look again because of the
world we live in today the most
important thing first
is if you're going to succeed in
business you have to know who your ideal
client is
who is the client that is your ideal
that if you built your business on that
it would grow if the economics of the
economy dropped they'd still buy from
you that's the person you want to
cherish you want to fall in love with
you don't fall in love with your product
you want to fall in love with your
client and you want to know more about
them than anybody else because i always
say life is the dance between what you
desire most and what you fear most so if
you can expand your desires and
breakthrough your fears you expand your
life massively so for the people that
are really watching i think the more you
know about those needs if you can do
more for them than anybody else then you
go to the second piece which is add more
value than anyone in your industry if
you do more for others than anybody else
and you don't just do it for a day or a
week or a month you do it like i always
tell people most people overestimate
what they're going to do in a year but
they underestimate what they do in a
decade or two or three if you do that
year after year
the word spreads and you start to build
a brand and if you do that for a decade
or more you can start to actually
dominate the industry so you got to know
everything about them you got to add the
value and you've got to find an
irresistible offer
tom shoes irresistible offer he took a
product quite frankly product's not very
good at all
but the offer is really great if i buy
and wear these crappy shoes you'll get
another pair and you'll give them to
someone who doesn't have shoes i'm in
and now a bunch of people mop they're
doing it with glasses and things of that
nature or 99 cents on itunes i mean
people are getting everything for free
why should i buy it
better fidelity easy clear but only 99
cents that offer zappos
right tony shea is a good friend of mine
he comes up and he joins the founders
and they're living in this little house
up in san francisco and they're totally
frustrated we're spending all this money
and we're trying to sell women's shoes
online and it's not working how come
well they got to try them on and well
they aren't doing it because they want
to spend the money on shipping it and
tony shea changes the offer he says look
we're going to let people
order as many shoes as they want we're
going to pay for all the shipping and if
they don't like anything send them back
and pay the shipping back now if you're
the investor in the company what do you
say are you crazy we're going to go
bankrupt because you don't understand
our ideal customer these women they have
a different relationship to shoes than
you and i do women say shoes equal
happiness a woman can put on one shoe
she's one woman she changes shoes she's
another woman right and he said they're
going to get these shoes and we're going
to pay if you get them there they're not
going to send them back 99 of the time
because if they like the shoe even if it
doesn't fit they'll convince themselves
it'll fit in the future right and when i
talk about this in like big seminars
women are laughing raising their hand
going yeah high five and it's true and
he built a business he sold for 1.2
billion dollars and he still runs it
because he wasn't doing it for the money
he loved building the culture and doing
this but he came up with that
irresistible offer so know more about
them make sure you have value massively
have an irresistible offer be three
things i'd start with if i gave you a
fourth one throw it in you better know
your numbers right i do these boot camps
and i bring in a guy that's just a
genius who gives them like an nba in
five hours it sounds like an
exaggeration but it's not he's done
billions of dollars in the deals and he
teaches them how to know their numbers
because most entrepreneurs that's not
their skill
they're good at marketing or creating a
product or innovating or selling or
whatever um but the financials is why
most people die because
you don't want an accountant you need a
cfo
and yet when you're a small company you
can't afford to see a focus they're like
you know 400 000
what's different about a cfo than
account it kind of just puts the numbers
in the right columns he'll tell you how
you have this much profit you go yay and
then you find out at the end of the year
there was no cash
profit and cash are not the same thing
oh my god what am i gonna do so
understanding your numbers and
understanding that profit is a theory
right you got a big profit and no cash
you have to understand how that works
and you got to just take the time to get
that skill so that numbers become
intelligence because if you have the
right numbers and you know what they
mean
now you can make better decisions you
make better decisions you're going to
win in the psychological realm
um everyone's going to measure
themselves differently because everyone
values things differently some people
value success or significance some
people value love more some value just
basic levels of certainty
so when i look at the specific metrics i
really look at
metrics of what are the things that need
to be measured to know if your life is
going to work or not so i look at it as
our whole lives are guided moment to
moment by the state we're in learning
how to change your state
not
not fake but to go from pissed off
frustrated freaked out to back in your
center or creative or
determined or something that's going to
move you forward it's going to create a
better quality of life for you and
others that's a critical skill set so
the most powerful decision we make most
of us don't make it consciously is what
are we going to focus on
we don't focus on everything we focus on
a small number of things and that's what
we experience in life
because you could be focusing right now
on the blood rushing through your left
ear or the touch of your clothes against
your skin but you don't
most of what your brain does is distort
delete and generalize that makes life
simple
and the problem is you distort delete
and generalize you miss a lot of your
life
and focus right down equals feeling
whatever you focus on you're going to
feel even if it's not true
if i asked you there are two things you
could focus on what you have or what's
missing which one do you spend more time
focusing on if your brain is constantly
focusing what's missing how can you ever
sustain happiness no matter how
successful you become it is impossible
what happens when you focus on what you
have
you feel alive you feel no scarcity you
feel joy how many of you have lots of
things in your life that if you focused
on it you could feel grateful for you
could feel excited about how many got
lots of things like this now say i
but it doesn't exist unless you focus on
it and we all have patterns of focus
do you tend to focus more on what you
can control or what you can't control
what's outside your control what is
someone going to feel is constantly
focused on what's missing and what they
can't control
sad frustrated angry depressed
so why are they still depressed because
they are still focusing on what's
missing
and they're focused on what they can't
control and i'll add one more do you
tend to focus more on things from the
past
the present or the future we all do all
three but if you're going to spend your
predominant time and you want enjoyment
it's the present if you want to create a
great life it's the future so it's a
balance between the present and future
so i live my life where i keep learning
i keep growing i keep loving i keep
laughing and i'm trying to leave a
decent legacy of a meaningful life by
constantly looking for ways i can be
helpful and
my prayer simple prayer before i walk on
every stage is use me use me lord and
and when you do that it's like if you
get out of the way my greatest gift is
getting out of the way i know that
sounds silly to some people but it's
really true i'm not an ultra religious
person but i'm extremely spiritual and i
believe the force of life comes through
me it comes through you comes through
all of us and the only thing gets in the
way is all the beliefs we have how it's
supposed to be all the expectations we
have and i have them too but i keep
weeding them out sir john templeton is
probably one of the greatest investors
in history
people don't know his name uh he started
out with nothing
um he wasn't sir he wasn't from the
country came to the u.s and he decided
that he wanted to understand wealth and
so he saved ten thousand dollars a huge
amount of money in those days and when
hitler invaded poland he developed a
belief his belief was you make your
money in times of maximum pessimism like
if you around at 2008.99 you remember
what it was like right
you could have bought you know the sands
in las vegas you get about their stock
for two dollars and 28 cents today at 67
wow it's a 3 000 return not bad um you
could have bought uh citibank for less
than a buck
right so people in those times he
understood that and so what he did was
and everybody thought the world was
going to end he took ten thousand
dollars he bought every stock on new
york stock exchange it was a dollar or
less including companies everybody
thought were going bankrupt but when
things are bad people think it's going
to be bad forever when things are good
they think it's going to be good forever
and they're always wrong life's cyclical
so there's a season for everything so
once we got through world war ii and a
few years later guess what those same
stocks made him a billionaire so when i
asked him i said what's the secret to
wealth his responsibility touched me
goes you know it you teach it i said
what's that he said gratitude and i said
why do you say that he said because if
you got a billion dollars and every day
you live pissed off and frustrated the
quality of your life is called pissed
off and frustrated right but if you have
nothing
but you're euphorically grateful for
whatever you have you're the richest
person that you're going to know he said
so it doesn't matter how much money you
got if you don't have gratitude so i do
the same thing by the way i have a
process i call priming where i get up
every morning i do mine in the morning
i just radical change to my body kind of
alter my state and then i do 10 minutes
i never miss and my first three and a
half minutes is what i'm really grateful
for and i make myself think of at least
one of those three that's something
really simplistic instead of something
giant you know the wind on my face the
look in one of my kids eyes you know
something of that nature and then i do
three minutes of strengthening healing
and i do three minutes of what i'm going
to create my world and i do that for a
minimum of 10 minutes every day because
i believe you have to condition you
don't just hope that stuff shows up you
set your intention each morning
every day yeah people say what does it
take to be happy i say one word progress
if you're not there yet but you are
starting to make some progress on your
body or progress on your relationship or
progress on your career your finances
you're gonna feel good and when you
achieve it how long do you feel good for
not very long because when you achieve
it you stop growing you kind of
celebrate nothing wrong with that but
how long after you get that thing you
wanted are you happy a week a month a
year almost never a year it's a short
time and the reason is we're not
supposed to just sit there at the table
of success and celebrate for years
we need to grow to feel alive and
everything in the universe grows or it
dies but when we grow we have something
to give and when we give that people
often say human beings are selfish i've
been selfish i'm sure you've been at
times but that's not my core and it's
not anybody's and i'll prove it to you
when you're having all of you at home
and all of you here when you have
something great in your life that
happens you learn something you
experience something beautiful what's
the first thing you want to do tell
people share somebody what you love why
because when you share with it it
expands see pleasure is something coming
in from the outside happiness is
something inside you that you share
and if you happiness is what people
really want pleasure you get pleasure
from alcohol or sex or anything but some
people there it's all about me when
you're taking what's inside yourself
because you've grown and you're giving
to someone you love your children or
friend a girlfriend boyfriend a
co-worker anybody there's an aliveness
you can't feel by yourself there's only
so much pleasure you can feel happiness
and joy comes when that expansion is
shared in the early stages of me i
myself as an entrepreneur i started all
these companies from scratch
and then i met a gentleman the gentleman
started mtv
and we had this really cool conversation
he said you know tony it took me
you know a decade and a half to really
build up mtv and he said and then i
built another company and he said tony
you know what i realized it takes like
seven years that was his number in his
head on average to go from scratch to
build something that's really stable and
strong and so forth you know he goes i
realize there's only so many seven year
cycles in my body and he said but if i
went to a company that already has been
around for seven ten twenty years and i
bring my ability my vision my ability to
grow that business my ability to inspire
the people my ability to produce
resourcefulness
then i get a multiplied effect and he
goes tony you're the best in the world
at what you do but damn you work your
tail off and so he asked me if i'd come
speak he one of the companies he took
over with century 21 real estate
and he said why haven't you ever spoken
for us because your company asks me over
and over but they're cheap you know they
want to pay me a hundred thousand
dollars my fee is a quarter of a million
he goes oh he goes we'll pay the
quarterback i said no for you i'll do it
for free because he's a friend and i'm
learning from him so i came into this
speech and afterwards he sat me back
down he goes tony
there are ten thousand people here he
says i know like all my financial guys
they all looked you but you're like a
rock star from middle america these
people in gold jackets selling real
estate he goes do you know how much our
business increased in those four months
and i remember the exact number was like
22 or 23 or something goes too much
money you made me and you got nothing
he said let me give you some advice
go find people that have some form of
momentum that you can turn it around
and get a piece of that and that's how i
change so what i looked for were
businesses that i felt tremendous
emotional connection to because i
thought they'd touch people's lives in
some way
and i looked for partners that were
geniuses but where i could bring my own
genius to it where one plus one equals
five or at least three not two and by
doing that i got pieces of these
different companies and then it just
grew and grew and grew and grew so i'm
in
virtual reality of company called nextvr
my partners are geniuses and we just
lock down the exclusive for the nba so
instead of monday night football we have
tuesday night nba and you literally it's
like you're on the court you can look
and it feels like you can reach out and
touch lebron it's mind-boggling and
there's no chords or computer it's all
done off your phone with an app it's
mind-boggling um we also have the
exclusive for live nation for all
concerts so you can be right there next
to jay-z or beyonce like you feel like
you can touch them right i've
accompanied us number one guy in stem
cells in the world i have a company that
does genetics you know that's just
genius i've got companies that are in
the education space i bought adweek with
a group of partners i have my financial
companies so the diversity i have is
mind-boggling but that's also the secret
to investing
you know if you've got all your eggs in
one basket there's a problem you need to
make sure you run your business really
successful give it your all not start 20
of them
but once that business really is strong
and your investments are strong then you
can build a second one most people they
build a business and then it's not going
as well as they want so i start another
business because it feels more exciting
and it's like you have one child you're
not taken care of so let's have a second
child and a third child and it just
doesn't work but the diversity of it
also makes me excited so i manage 12 of
them actively the others i have such
great partners like you know i own
uh you know the major league soccer new
franchise in la i'm a partner in that uh
it's called the la football club but my
partner's peter guber owns the la
dodgers and owns the golden state
warriors and about as smart a human as
you could ever have in the sports field
and then i bought um uh in the esports
field you know it's mind-boggling people
we fill whole stadiums now people
watching people play video games so i
bought team liquid which with my
partners with peter and everyone else
and and so i mean the opportunities are
just amazing because i'm partnering with
people have skills that are the best in
the world and i'm bringing mine and when
you combine them you know you get a
greater impact everyone has different
goals and dreams and desires but as i
travel around the world to 100 countries
i started going holy i'm seeing the same
problems what's underneath it i began to
see that there are these same six human
needs that we all have the same needs we
all have a need for certainty that we
can avoid pain and we can have some
pleasure some comfort we all need
uncertainty we need variety or we feel
dead inside if you're totally certain
you're bored if you have total variety
you're like freak out and it's not a
balance it's learning which of these you
need more as a person everyone's
developed a different set of values in
that area um need the need for
significance to feel unique special
important they need to feel loved the
need to grow and they need to contribute
some people value certainty at the top
of their list that's their center of
their target i don't want to do anything
unless i know it's going to work i don't
do anything unless it's the same if you
change anything they freak out
if certainty is the number one thing on
your list everyone has the same needs
but if it's number one i know how your
life's gonna be i can predict the
direction of your life and therefore the
destination to some extent
if you're driven by love first you want
certainty too but love is higher you're
going to behave very differently than if
you're driven by significance i have to
be the one
your experience in business was
trying to be significant by making
enough money and being successful enough
that you would feel what you really want
which is that feeling of love what you
call uh uh
not what would you call lottery
camaraderie thank you camaraderie so
that feeling of it's really love it's
it's the friendship it's the camaraderie
it's that component that's what really
drives you and so you figure how to
organize your life where that's the
driving force and now look what you've
done you flourished and everyone around
you is flourishing so i look to see
which of those needs are the top two on
your list because they control your life
the two that most people have 90 of the
planet if you said of all these
needs
which one do you really focus on most
day to day everybody wants love what do
you focus on most people focus on being
significant we live in a facebook world
where people fake their life put new
filters make it look different than it
really is tell stories that you know are
totally full of it to make themselves
look good because we live in this kind
of false world where significance is
more important than love right and it
separates us
and the other one that we see most often
is certainly people want to be certain
before they can do something you
couldn't have started a business like
you had if you were absolutely certain
before you started you can never build a
business with that you can never build a
great relationship because if it's based
on certainty then everybody's got to
stay the same never change which means
you're never going to grow which means
you're going to be miserable right so my
metrics are i want to find out what's
driving you
i want to see is it healthy or unhealthy
you can have two people be driven by
significance though and do it with a
different
set of rules that's the second piece i
measure the beliefs or rules of how to
fulfill that target
so
osama bin laden
certainty driven
love driven contribution dividend
significance driven not hard to figure
out
on a 0-10 he was a 10 for significance
he was the whatever i'm making the
number up he was like the 27th child of
his father 22nd child most people know
that
totally insignificant not skilled took
his dad's money went over to afghanistan
and suddenly because he had money he
became significant and he started he
wasn't even part of that movement at
that stage it shaped him so what does he
do he's going to figure out his model of
the world is i'm significant if i
destroy you
right
on that same day of 9 11 there were men
and women in the fire
police department that were also driven
by significance and contribution
and they went into that building knowing
they're likely going to die to save a
stranger
both people driven to have a significant
life one is by taking life one is by
giving their own life
so
once you understand the metrics using
your language of what's driving you and
then the rules or beliefs that what does
it take for you to feel loved it's
different for everybody what does it
take for you to feel certain some people
need a billion dollars some people just
need to trust god there are things you
obviously can't control
but there are plenty of things you can
control you can influence most things
but you can completely control your
experience of life and we forget that
when every day you turn on the news or
it follows you in your pocket and keeps
telling you the worst scenario i mean
people think that things are going to be
good forever when it's going great and
that's still
life is cyclical right there's always a
new challenge or problem you become
better if you face it but also when
things are going terrible they think
it's going to terrible forever
we're in winter it's going to be a
longer winter than i i want and you
probably want they're going to be people
five years from now still wearing a mask
in their mind because it's kind of like
the depression generation they're going
to overreact but there's also going to
be so many new opportunities so winter's
followed by spring baby you know the
darkest nights always fall by the day
and that's trite sounding but it's often
true
so it's like we need to take control so
what gives me excitement to see people
take back control of their life and not
fall into the trap of being a robot or
fitting into everybody else's plans if
you really want to get lasting change
real results that stick around what do
you got to do what are the most
important things you've learned tony in
that area i tell people the most common
thing people talk about is how they want
to make a change in their life but
everybody wants a change but nobody
wants to work out you know everybody
wants muscle but nobody wants to train
see one of the challenges that we have
in our lives is we don't realize that
the process of training ourselves the
process of conditioning ourselves
actually feels incredible once you get
that initial momentum but most people
don't
why why do so many people say oh i lost
100 pounds you know the same 10 pounds
10 times you know or they'll tell me you
know i'm on my fourth day without a
cigarette man i'm doing really good if
you're counting the days
it's not lasting change you just count
the days you can tell people how long
you lasted if you want lasting change
you've got to give up this idea of
trying something you get aside you're
going to commit to mastery and when i
say commit to mastery what i mean by
that is
most people dabble
they they talk about well i'd like to
change my body i'd like to change make
my relationship better i'd like to have
more passion there but they don't know
what to do and even if they did they
don't have enough detail to be able to
follow through
they haven't made the shifts and their
own emotion and their psychology to
follow through and it isn't that
difficult but there is a path and it
requires consistency
think about it everybody overeats some
of the time everybody gets angry or
frustrated or sad or depressed some of
the time your life is not controlled by
what you do some of the time it's what
you do consistently
and here's the secret
whatever you want to make better you
better make sure you measure it more
often
think about it if you want to lose
weight and you never look at a scale
that's how people find themselves 20 30
40 50 pounds overweight or even 10 or 15
because it just kind of happens slowly
and all at once you know why do
businesses go out of business you know
things are okay okay and then all of a
sudden they're in trouble overnight it's
not overnight all of our success and
failure in life comes from little
decisions little actions little moments
failure isn't an overnight event it's
failure to make the phone call it's
failure to say i love you it's failure
to take care of your body
it's failure to invest some time in
yourself so you keep growing and
expanding and not just reacting to the
world that's constantly demanding your
attention
it's success comes from doing the right
things also little things saying i love
you taking the time for what matters
most your body your mind your spirit
your emotion
having a plan
and measuring your progress
my number one favorite question and the
time that most people use it is if
you're really frustrated or sad or
worried or depressed or you think
something horrible has happened my
favorite question asked myself is what
else could this mean and i make myself
come up at least three different
meanings because what happens is beliefs
become self-fulfilling see once you
believe something you don't see anything
else i've done this with your audience
before i said you look around the room
and find brown everybody looks around
and i say now with your eyes closed tell
me you saw that was red and nobody sees
much red i said hope you guys look for
red may find more red why do you find
more red because you get what you look
for your beliefs condition you to find
and then i say how many saw i said you
even saw things that weren't there how
many saw beige stuff called it brown
just to feel successful they all laugh
you know how many saw burgundy called
red they all laugh and the reason is
because once we're after something we'll
even make the color different to feel
successful if you think somebody's mean
you'll find meanness in anything that's
not there if you think somebody's your
dear friend and they do something
terrible you'll say oh they're having a
bad day so our beliefs control us so
unquestioned beliefs
that produce stress those are the ones
you've got to question and there's a
there's a great lady out she wrote a
book called the work her name is byron
katie and she's dear friend of mine and
she has this four question format that
i'd recommend anybody looking at to
question your beliefs because all our
pain comes from believing something that
makes us stress rather than saying hey
there's lots of options in our country
today we see people on two sides of
things we're all brothers and sisters we
all take any issue guns right
people make the other side evil on both
sides everybody wants our children
protected everyone wants our our you
know homes and our churches and our
schools to be safe let's stop beating
each other up and doing that that's the
only way we'll make progress is find
what we do agree on we might have
different ideas of how to do that but
that doesn't make the other person evil
once you start believing the other
person's evil all you're really doing is
feeding your own significance your own
ego i'm right you're wrong and that'll
never solve a damn thing do you want to
be right you want to be in love that's
why i tell intimate relationships right
you know it's the same thing in life
right if you work for mcdonald's and i
forget what it was back then but it was
minimum wage then as well he said tony
do it for mcdonald's
you're gonna make nothing because the
job is too easy anyone can learn that
job in a few minutes he said i'm not
being derogatory but that's why you make
minimum wage and because i brought up a
billionaire guy that made a billion two
that year was a hedge fund guy and i
don't seem so unfair when it's school
teachers you know making thirty thousand
dollars a year back then and he said
tony that's what it seems like on the on
the surface but he said what did that
man actually do
he got people 38 return when most people
are getting 2 percent he allowed
children to go to college he provided
businesses non-profits he had hundreds
of billions of dollars and he made a
billion
he said that's massive added value he
said so your job in life or what your
your father's didn't learn
is you got to work harder in yourself
than you do your job you've got to
literally become worth more because
you're going to do more for others than
anybody else and i became obsessed with
that you know now i have 74 companies we
do six billion dollars in business and
everything from ai to you know lafc
sports team because i don't know when he
was there in l.a to you know you name it
nice resort in fiji and all that has
come because in each of those industries
i come in and obsess on how do i do more
for others in this industry than anybody
else and when you do that you prosper so
i got that from jim rohn connection
right and versus significance i want to
be the best
so i got to be different but i want to
be in community with you i want to be
close to you i want i want love and i
want connection but see what most people
like you see this and and great actors
or uh great uh entertainers they'll come
to me and in the beginning they work so
hard to be significant to be unique to
be special to be important what they
really wanted was love but now people
stop on the street and they'll say to me
they don't even know who i am they just
want my time they just want this they
want a picture they don't respect my
family i don't respect it you'll hear
them so upset
what they wanted was the love but see
we we can have both but the more
significant i am the more unique i am
the more separate i am from you the more
connected i am then some people go yeah
but where am i where am i special so the
finding that balance between the two is
what makes people feel alive and we can
meet all these needs in positive ways or
negative ways you get significance by
tearing other people down oh they don't
they're lucky they they don't care they
took advantage of somebody you know
anything about them you see people dealt
with famous people all the time why are
they tearing them down because if i
don't feel good about myself if i can
make you smaller i look like i'm moving
up but you're not and it doesn't work
but if you do things where you
significantly love someone if you care
for someone you're the most significant
person in life if you try to prove
you're significant then you have kind of
the trump effect even people like him
will say you know sometimes he can push
people aside because he's telling
everybody how special he is i'm not
making a political statement i'm saying
that gets in the way of relationship if
we're going to connect we got to not
make ourselves significant we got to
find out what's significant the other
person and honor it when i was
32 33
maybe 34 somewhere in that range i was
really frustrated because i love what i
do for a living it's emotional rewards
are gigantic but it's not a it's not a
business that has a great deal of you
know opportunity for maximizing profit
because this is a low margin business
and i didn't get into it's like what's
the best business get in is this i'm an
artist i want to help people change
their lives this is my this is my
mission
so
you know we were in the 9 10
margin and
it doesn't take much of a challenge when
your margin is that small to have a real
challenge in your business so i called a
group of billionaire friends of mine
that i've coached over the years and i
always want to be the giver i never
asked for anything but i said to them
look i have these
seven or eight opportunities that are
being put in front of me that look
incredible i still want to run my core
business but i'd love to get your
coaching i've coached you guys would you
be willing to coach me just for a couple
hours so i brought them all here in new
york had this incredible meeting i'll
never forget
and i decided i wanted to add value so i
introduced them to each other they all
knew of each other they're all kings of
titans of business some some were
friends and then i said so let me show
you the good the bad the ugly of my
story and so i told them my
entrepreneurial story from the very
beginning no money the ups and downs the
near-death experiences
and i was watching their eyes get this
big because a lot of them they didn't
start businesses like that right some of
them started businesses by getting a
billion dollar loan one guy right he was
able to do because it's financial
backing
and so i can see them getting more and
more intense and long story short at the
end they're like
stop stop stop you shouldn't do any of
these opportunities they're all
wonderful opportunities you've got to go
back and maximize your business you have
to maximize your business and one of the
guys had just been one of my seminars
when i unleash the power within seminar
and he told me came up to me and said
tony the most incredible thing i've ever
done in my life because tony you work so
hard you're on stage 12 14 hours a day i
don't know how you hold people's
attention people won't sit for a
two-hour movie three-hour movie and you
got people so you're never going to want
to do this when you're like 42 you know
like 32. same guy three weeks later goes
you're not working hard enough on your
business i'm like what the hell right
and what it was was they all reacted
because they're used to a different type
of business
and
one of the guys afterwards says hey that
was near tears because i walked in
thinking on the greatest business
opportunities in the world and i walk
back feeling like i'm a piece of you
know what right and one of the guys the
billionaire says to me he goes hey tony
where are you staying about the four
seasons he goes i'm staying there too
three blocks away can i walk with you i
want to get your advice on something i
thought who me dumb f i'm the one you
want this advice from right and he says
to me i'll never forget he goes
tony you know in front of the
underwear company he goes up i got an
offer
make me about a billion nine
so i kind of i gotta decide do i do i
sell the company do i build it up bigger
and then sell it or do i keep it for my
son
and i said i said bill i said i love you
to death i said you already know the
answer you just you want me to confirm
it for you let's be honest i said first
of all if you sell the company now get a
billion eight billion nine more it's not
going to change your life one iota you
have the planes the cars the homes the
all that stuff plenty of cash i'm not
going to change but if you sell when the
business is not at its peak you'll
resent yourself later on you'll be mad
because you're a guy that loves to
maximize he goes oh you're so right and
i said keeping it for your son he's five
right does he want to be the underwear
king i don't think so i said go build it
a little bit more to the level you know
it is and then sell it right and he goes
oh my god it's so brilliant so great but
what i got on this conversation that
changed my life was i hated it i felt
they didn't understand and they didn't
understand a bunch but i said there's
got to be some truth in there and then i
saw this uh story about this guy
who spent i think it was 17 years
looking for the spanish galleon his name
was mel i'm playing a last name but it
was very famous in the 1990s 80s
and
he literally
made no money found nothing like 16
years into it he had to convince people
to give him more money one of his
members his crew died it was the most
brutal approach how could you possibly
keep going out there
looking for treasure
and not finding it for five years not
give up or 10 16. i think he went 18 if
i remember correctly and
he found a half a billion dollars of the
gold so i asked myself a question
i said
what would make a guy
go 16 17 18 years with no evidence of
success and keep doing and convince
people to give him money and keep going
working seven day weeks he'd have to
believe something different than other
people what would he have to believe i
thought first he'd have to believe the
treasure's there
i didn't believe the treasure was in my
business
so you didn't find it right
second you'd have to believe i will find
it
and third to go that many years you'd
have to believe it's worth it
and i shifted those three beliefs in my
business
and i cr like once i committed
completely to that business and nothing
else
i grew the business like crazy and i end
up selling half that business for 200
million dollars the business that looked
like it would never make anything
when i did that i said now i'm a
successful entrepreneur now i'll take on
some other companies because i'm not
bs'ing myself i've really built it this
idea you're gonna go build nine
companies nice ego stroke no way you can
give them the focus that you need but
today i can do more with my pinky than i
used to be able to work in 20-hour days
because i know more people i have more
context i have more strategy i have more
tools and so you've got to make sure you
maximize something and really make a
real business you want to know your real
test could you sell the business
tomorrow for a significant multiple if
not don't start another business or get
rid of his business sell it and start
something fresh but most people are
always looking for what's easier and it
always looks easier what you really want
to do is maximize the business you're in
if you want to break through not just a
little change you know you can change
laterally you know you can go from being
pissed off to frustrated right doesn't
help that much right but if you really
want to change most people are trying to
change they want to lose weight they
want to make money they go how do i do
it they look for the strategy but i like
all three of you to think of three s's
strategies where most people go first
like how do i do it but how hard is it
really truly to be fit and have energy
it's not that complex it's not like
reserved for the one percent or
expensive to learn you have to interrupt
you have to hide from the answers to
those things the real problem is the
second s story
see the reason the person is making
progress they may not know what to do
sometimes that's true but some don't
know what they do and they don't do what
they know that's most people yes and so
why they have a story that says it's a
set of beliefs they tell themselves over
and again i've tried everything or if
they're single all the good ones are
gone you know you know whatever the
story is and if you tell yourself a
story over and over again you know
hitler used to say tell a story big
enough loud enough long enough people
believe you well we're hitler to
ourselves we convince ourselves the
thing we really need that was you always
come up with lousy story when you're in
a lousy state yeah and so the number one
thing i show people do is how to change
their emotional state when you're
feeling tired or frustrated when you
learn how to change your body so that
you really feel excited it isn't fake
when you learn how to change your
biochemistry which is what i teach
people to do when for example when
you're in love when you when you're
upset with someone do you ever notice
how you can now remember everything that
they've ever done that ever upset you
right
and when you're in love when you're
totally love everybody make the sound of
being alive try it
oh it's been a while for some of you
clearly let's try it again out of your
mind and love you can't stop thinking
about the person make the sound how that
feels go for it everybody
i will work on that
but when you're in love what's wrong
with life
what's wrong with anything when you're
loving oh we have no money who cares
we're in love right
so your emotional state controls the
story you have about your life and then
your story determines whether you find a
strategy or even if you know the
strategy whether you really do it or not
when people say i tried what they're
really telling me is i have a story that
says i should try this but it's really
not going to work so i give it a half
weird attempt and it didn't work and i
can tell people i tried what you really
got to do is learn to change your
emotion your state
change your story and then you can find
the strategy or you can make the
strategy to work people ask what does it
take to succeed the one answer i give
them is hunger
[Music]
that hunger is the greatest asset that
you'll see in everybody from richard
branson to google or an apple or
facebook these you know giant companies
you got to become a master of your
ability to turn on your determination or
your creativity or your hunger or your
passion or whatever it is it's going to
take for you to get from where you are
to where you really want to be
intelligence is so valuable but there
are so many smart people i can't fight
the weight of a paper bag hunger is that
part of you that says i will not stop i
will not get off i will not settle for
less than i can be or do or share or
give so you really have to decide the
most important decision is do i want to
be happy will i commit to being happy
more importantly than happy
sometimes you'd be so happy you smile so
much your face hurts right you need
variety
am i committed to living in a beautiful
state
even when it doesn't go my way even when
it rains on my parade even when my
biggest fear shows up because i can't
control whether your husband or wife
will live or die or get sick or leave
you or get a divorce i don't want any of
that to happen to any human being i hate
suffering i do anything i can help
people not suffer
but i can't control that you can
you can there are people have lost their
arms lost their sight there have been
people that have been through the most
horrific experiences of life and they
found a way to still be happy because
they've made the decision that life is
too short to suffer i've interviewed
dozens and hundreds over the years but
dozens that like have impacted my soul
that made me realize i can change this
i've just gotten used to it i bought
into the theory that this
this survival software that's constantly
running and making you suffer that
that's normal no that's what the mind
will do and mind has been around forever
what i'm going to do is something
different and the way i get out of
suffering
i give myself a 90 second rule it's
really simple i say look if i feel
myself starting to feel that stress
feeling that pissed offness or upsetness
or concern or worry about my kid
whatever i realize that's not going to
make it better life's too short to
suffer and then i just kind of breathe
slowly slow everything down and i just
watch the thought go by and go look at
that crazy thought cause everybody said
crazy thoughts everybody thought i'm
gonna kill that son of a [ __ ] right and
then you don't kill them cause you don't
believe that thought
it's the thoughts that are stressful
that you believe that mess you up when
you question them
you break the pattern the more i've done
this like a muscle the more i've trained
myself to do it i can authentically tell
you now it takes a lot for something to
take more than 90 seconds for me now and
the level of joy
surpasses all the money you could ever
have in a million years and then the
money it's easier to make money because
you're not attached you don't have the
fears you don't have the scarcity that
people have because you feel so rich
already right now i always tell people
don't wait to be rich what is that
richness it's abundance it's joy it's
happiness it's contribution it's getting
out of yourself
because as long as we're thinking about
oh my god
i lost something or you did something i
have less love less respect less money
if i think lost less or because you did
something
or because i did something i'm never
going to have what i want in my life
lost less than ever those three thought
patterns
they're the source of all suffering and
the antidote
see it for what it really is know it's
bs
and find something to appreciate most
people who start a business very often
will start two and three four more and
the reason they do it is because the
first one isn't succeeding or they're no
longer patient that's exactly right and
so what happens that person is they're
never going to be successful in most
cases unless they get lucky bounce
across something that's easier to do but
most people are always looking for that
next level what my view is is it's great
to test all these things but you've got
to find what is your flagship what is it
that you're going to commit your soul to
because if you don't do that the
inevitable challenge are going to come
up and you're going to then move on to
something 100 enjoyable and so the other
thing to look at is business is about
constantly not only adding such massive
value doing more for others anybody else
but it's also simultaneously about your
own psychology it's your ability to go
through thresholds of control um it's
like
i can remember when i didn't have fifty
thousand dollars keep the doors open on
my company i had 12 employees and 11
wanted to quit because i hated the
person running the show and 50 000 would
be like 500 million to me today and i
figured out how to get through that
threshold and once i did like all the
problems related that were handled i
know you've done this as well and then i
you know i had a 5 million lawsuit was
totally unfair and unjust and i finally
had just the amount of time energy and
learning how to bite the bullet dude
five million was more than i could
remember then i had a partner
who took a company was losing a million
dollars a day and turned into 1.5
billion in positive ebitda i'm not
mentioning names amway
and he wanted me to join him in business
with some other partners not doing the
multi-level side did the business put in
10 million bucks we all put in 10
million 40 million to that
but i signed joint and several which i
didn't understand in those days what
that meant
and two of my partners were supposedly
billionaires and they went broke we
bought some more companies i ended up
with 120 million dollars in debt that i
was on the hook for no one else had any
money and i'm getting up to do a seminar
i wanted to throw up it was a new
threshold of control so you know when
you ski or you snowboard and you think
you're maybe you're just new at it and
you think you're going down a blue or
green it turns out to be a double black
and you're like
yeah
and so you have two choices one is you
start to go down and you freak out
you're going to die you slam on the
ground and try to hang on for dear life
or the other is baby you focus on where
you want to go you find a way to curve
you find a way to cut and once you do it
a couple of times you get used to it you
have no more fear of that element now my
biggest one
out of that that led me to a billion i
have 31 companies now to give you an
idea seven different industries as
diverse as like uh you know stem cells
to virtual reality we have the exclusive
the nba now virtually how to give an
example
we do i got 1200 employees were on three
continents and we got five billion
dollars in sales but i did that because
i first stayed on one freaking yeah
exactly i'm so masterful at it the only
way to deal with fear that i've found in
my life is a couple of ways one of those
ways
is to turn it on itself and ask yourself
what am i afraid of i'm afraid of that i
got to be more afraid of what i'm going
to miss out on missing out on my mission
missing out who i'm supposed to be
missing in other words if you're not
going to get rid of fear then use fear
use fear or it uses you it's that simple
so you gotta say okay what's the price
if i just stay doing this what's the
price what i need to really get scared
if i learn all this and i don't follow
through
that's something to be scared about
and then that fear will get you over
your fear it'll push you through turn
fear on itself
second way you can do it is use what
you've probably heard me say because
i've used it so i was 17 is my little
rocking chair test right
i'm gonna i'm gonna sit myself in my
rocking chair i'm 85 years old and
looking back on my life and i say i
didn't do this
or i did if you find your passion
you're going to have this tremendous
energy it's sustainable energy
but momentum requires you always do the
next thing to keep the momentum going
and the reason
you get yourself in a passionate place
is so that you change your life and the
only thing that changes your life is
making a decision
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions you
don't make decisions when you're like
huh i don't know what do you think all
right let's decide
if you make a decision in a state
without momentum if you make a decision
from a place where there's no passion
you are not going to get momentum it
will kill momentum it's decide
commit
and resolve
some of you
in the past you've gotten momentum
you've gotten passionate you've even
made a decision
but
a decision is the first step decision is
like a war i got to do this or that all
right i'm gonna make myself do this
but commitment
is when you now after you've decided you
commit to do this for the long term
whether it's hard or easy doesn't matter
you're doing this
it takes it from this moment and it
carries into the future even when things
are difficult
and the third state is resolve
resolve
means it's done
it's like it doesn't even if you took
action it's done inside you so it's done
out there there's no question whatsoever
then once you decide
the only way the commitment and the
energy and the momentum continues is if
you take immediate massive what my
friends massive what
write down in your notes massive action
is the cure-all
massive action is the cure-all
if you're having a difficult time with
something your relationship isn't where
you want it to be your finances are not
where you want to be your body's not
where you want to be your business is
not where you want to be you need to
take massive action and if that doesn't
work try something else if that doesn't
work try something else keep going with
massive action and you will find the way
because it will give you momentum like
the most common question i've been asked
by the media in my entire life that
always makes me laugh is
don't you have bad days don't you have
days when you're like frustrated excited
and pissed off and you watch tv and you
eat cheetos and watch pornography and i
said well i do some of those things
and of course i do but when i it's like
an athlete i've built muscle over the
years so that it's not that i don't have
feelings i don't get hurt i don't feel
sad don't feel tired feel all those
things but they're not the dominant
force of my life it's a muscle the mind
is a muscle emotion is a muscle i mean i
think the most powerful muscles are the
invisible force muscles it's your
spiritual emotional muscles like courage
unused doesn't grow it shrinks so i put
my ass on the line regularly so that it
grows and when it keeps growing then
pretty soon the stuff that used to make
me crazy it doesn't touch me it's not
that i'm so great just i'm well trained
i've trained this mind i get up every
morning in my life you talk about
rebounder more crazy ideas everywhere in
my life if i'm near if i'm near any of
my homes and some places i perhaps i
have cryotherapy but my homes i have
these cold plungers and they're 56
degrees and the first thing i do is jump
in that cold point so there's not a
morning where i want to jump in that i
can't remember mine's like i can't wait
to jump in that thing but i don't
negotiate with myself i do it for two
reasons one there's a physical health
component it moves your lymph system and
the blood flushes through your whole
body but the main reason i do it even
more than that
is when i go up there i don't you know
people negotiate well i'm able to do it
tomorrow i'm going to do this or i'll
let me wait two more minutes till i'm
ready there's none of that with me for
decades i go i say we do i'm not here to
discuss this with my mind there's mind
and then there's soul and spirit and
soul and spirit my soul knows and when i
say jump you jump i'm not here to have a
discussion with you i always tell people
uh anticipation is power if you're
playing a video game against a child
it's pretty disastrous right maybe not
for you or maybe a different generation
but for me it's like you know it's not
the kid who's faster and smarter if they
played this game before like eight
million times so they know the first
shots here the second shot third shot
there and you're like reacting so when
you're reacting to things you fail so my
mentors have been people over the years
different people my earliest mentor was
a man named jim rohn he was a personal
development speaker just touched my life
then i was involved in neuro-linguistic
programming nlp when i was
21 22 23 years old i became partners
with a man named john grinder brilliant
man co-founder of that but in my last
couple decades it's been people like
peter guber who's owns the the la
dodgers and owns uh you know the golden
state warriors nba team and he's just
got 52 academy award nominations so he's
a mentor for me um a paul tutor jones i
coach but also i'm coached by him
because we get to pitch and catch um and
then you know i've got some people in my
life that you know like steve wynn is a
dear friend of mine
most of las vegas he's brilliant and
these guys are all 18 years my senior so
they know the road ahead and i'm able to
learn from them in advance and kind of
anticipate things and that to me is
incredibly valuable yeah what is the one
thing that you want people to understand
about control when they feel out of
control they feel they don't understand
the stock market like what's the one
message you want to you want people to
take home around control i think it's uh
that you have to become an owner and not
just a consumer you have to take a
percentage of what you earn as
simplistic as it sounds and automate it
so it comes off the top of what you earn
uh there's a gentleman that used work
for ups names theodore and theodore
robinson was this guy who never made
more than fourteen thousand dollars a
year and yet he retired with 70 million
dollars and gave away 35 million was
alive how did he do it he became an
owner his best friend said to him listen
to me the most important thing in your
life is we're going to put a wealth tax
on you because a wealth tax i think 14
000 a year he goes we're going to make
you wealthy with this tax it's not a
government taxes tax for yourself so
we're going to take 20 of what you earn
and put it in an investment account let
it build up he said i can't afford that
he goes once it's automated you won't
notice
that's all he did that made him 70
million dollars so it's like people have
to understand that no matter how good
you are in business we all need a second
business with no employees and it takes
very little time something that once you
do your homework should take you you
know 15 minutes to an hour twice a year
to rebalance perhaps but outside of that
that's what this is this is a setting of
a business that will make you do well
when i was um hold when i was 20
24 years old 25 years old i worked with
a man named ken blanchard who wrote
those one minute manager books you
probably remember him evan yeah
really great guy and he i helped him
take five strokes off his golf game and
that made me god to him so and then he
was saying i want to return the favor
and he goes the best advice i got
growing my business was i was about to
come out with my first book
and he said a friend of mine who's very
wealthy said do not put that money in
your company let the leads go to your
company do not let the profits go and do
not spend those profits put that in a
separate account that nothing ever
touches because your business will eat
whatever resources you have what a
growing business does that and he said
tony i put that aside and during the
tough times that's what made me safe
well i did the same thing with that in
my original infomercials that alone made
me a wealthy man so when tough times
came i could withstand it so i see so
many business owners go yeah but i have
control of my business
you have influence over your business
yes you have more influence but there
are better entrepreneurs than you
perhaps out there as well or businesses
that get greater valuations in your
business will and so your ability to
grow you want to grow your own business
i always tell people you want to build
two businesses the business you're in
the business you're becoming and that
you want to have the business that
you're in and becoming an investment
business it's really simple once you set
it up and i think everybody's got to do
that if they really want to have
financial freedom because look the
marketplace changes competition changes
ibm was the head of the pack forever and
then some little kid from microsoft
comes along
and buys ms-dos for fifty thousand
dollars and then leases it to them and
makes himself three billion on that
little move alone he didn't even write
their software right you know he's doing
great and all of a sudden you know this
little company comes along a couple of
guys at stanford called google you know
and apple comes along so there's always
disruption and the disruption can be
competition it can be new technology it
could be a change in the culture so even
if you do everything right you could
lose i want people to have a back-up
plan this is the back-up plan breakdowns
it's certainly not something i
experience but it's not because i'm so
talented or so brilliant or so fearless
it's just
you're like an athlete you're an athlete
yeah you're in shape right you're not
gonna have a reaction in your body like
somebody who doesn't take care of
themselves
so you know i believe i don't believe in
emotional intelligence i think it's
useful but i'm more interested in
emotional fitness because intelligence
is a capability fitness is a state of
readiness interesting if you are fit you
can take that demand right now you can
deal with it you can deal with that
physical stress that emotional stress
same is true with psychological fitness
emotional fitness right so i'm pretty
fit and part of that is not because i'm
so smart part of this i i've taught this
for decades i remember i had a woman who
came on my seminars in
her early 80s probably and she would run
in this room five ten thousand people i
think was you know she wanted a couple
of ten thousand person events and she
would get in this front row and find her
way through there
and she'd jump and go for it at one
break she came up to signing a book for
her and she says she goes mr um i've
seen you at like eight of these
i've seen you like when you're really i
know i can hear your voice you're
hurting or you haven't slept and she
goes you always seem to be so up all the
time how come you're so up and i said
well probably i attend all these
seminars yeah so i'm teaching it so
there's a fitness of that but there's
also you know i've i've buried three
fathers and one mother and you know that
affects your life i've uh you know i've
had a physician look me in the eye and
say you have a tumor in your brain wow
and so i've had those moments that
when you've had extreme stress
and you push your way through it you
build psychological muscle it's like it
takes a lot to knock me off you know in
the early days we didn't have fifty
thousand dollars keep the doors open how
do we do it then i had you know
graduated to five million and i
graduated to uh a partner that mine who
kind of didn't do things well and i
ended up owning a hundred million
dollars because i had to take on his
debts 100 million dollars
and but when you do all that stuff you
know now my companies do five billion
you know a year so
uh
you you keep expanding what i would call
really the circle of your the threshold
of your influence sure you know
everybody has a threshold of control and
if you get beyond it you kind of freak
out so
it takes a little bit more i don't know
if you don't have breakdowns it's not a
breakdown do i get pissed off or get
frustrated or tired yeah but breakdown
honestly no there is another level
the only reason you keep seeing there
isn't is you feel so exhausted about
where you are but life the universe or
god is just testing you because there is
another level if this is good giant jump
to excellence giant
good poor to good to excellence
there's a level where all your dreams
are realized
there's a level that you've always
dreamed about it is real it has not gone
away
but it takes that extra burst when you
think there's nothing left there's no
way you've tried everything 10 million
times and you keep going it's almost
like god is saying if you keep hitting
this wall enough times i will see that
you will not stop that you are filled
with that level of determination faith
and courage and then the door opens
and you get to that next level but most
people don't know is
the next level is just
two millimeters above and it's called
outstanding ladies and gentlemen
outstanding
what's it called
what's it called
what's it called
outstanding magnificent unstoppable
extraordinary not excellent
it's a different level
it's a level where you are not one of
the best you are the best you know
what's amazing you only have to be two
millimeters more than everybody else and
you get everything you get the joy the
laughter the fun the family the passion
the economics the freedom the spirit
it's all there what jerry maguire called
the quan baby all of it
and it's just two million views above
and most excellent people give up
because they're exhausted and there's
some people to go the harder i hit it
the more i hit it sooner or later it's
going down i'm not stopping and when you
do that enough it pops open if you're
obsessed you know what you want you take
a massive action maybe you modeled
somebody figure out the right action so
you get there quicker and you're
executing
you still need a little grace
some people call it luck you could call
god
but i really believe that there's the
part we do and then there's the part
that comes to us but i do know
grace shows up a lot more when you do
the first two steps on your own and
grace shows up a lot more when you
acknowledge grace in your life when you
acknowledge that i was born in a world
where i didn't have to build this
internet that i can pull out of my
pocket to answer anything on earth i'm
driving on streets i didn't pave i'm
reading books i didn't have to write
that's the gift of our lives and i think
when we experience that grace we don't
just experience more achievement but we
start to experience more fulfillment and
grace not only affects your ability to
get there but it affects what you do and
how you you live once you are there it
really determines the quality of your
life because unless you live in a state
of gratitude
you know i i did an interview
with sir john templeton who as you know
is one of the first billionaire
investors and just a brilliant man he
came from nothing and he donated
anything with 750 they still do it the
templeton fund i think it's 750 million
a year it's bigger than the nobel fund
that he donates
and one day i asked him i said what is
the secret to wealth
and he looked at me pause this big smile
and his eyes got really bright like they
always did and he said tony it's what
you teach i said well i teach a lot of
things you know which thing he said
gratitude
he said because you and i tony know
billionaires that are miserable
and it's because they're not grateful
for what they have and we both know
people have no money seemingly but
they're so grateful for their health for
their husband for their wife for their
children they're so grateful that god
they're so grateful for their life that
they're rich
you know so i think i think it starts
with that gratitude it starts with that
connection to grace as simplistic as
that sounds and so it's not enough just
to have your financial plan you have all
the money and be miserable let's have
the money and be really rich emotionally
psychologically failure is part of life
i mean
the difference for me though is i look
at failure as a stepping stone to
success it's a speed bump
i know i'm gonna fail um but it's not
failure if you learn something and so
gosh i've made so many mistakes i've
screwed so many things up but every time
i do it just becomes
it becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes you know it's
like here's what i've done i think i
have the ability to influence people
because i talk about my failures i talk
about all the things that mess me up but
i showed people that i didn't let it
stop me and you don't need to stop you
and i think i think that's really the
secret that area and if everything you
touched was successful
i wasn't going to relate to people as
much no you'll be related and also it's
be total and everyone knows
and also you'd be bored silly i mean
think about it if you just said i want
this to happen i want this and it
happened
you know
people don't value what they don't fight
for you know it's like you see kids
sometimes in it you know your parents
will say you're not going to value this
if you don't work for it and you're
kidding going i'll value it just give it
to me right but it's true you know the
things we've worked the hardest for we
value the most so i think you know
the purpose of the goal is not getting
it anyway the purpose of goal you know
is what who you become who you become is
going to make you happy or who's going
to make you sad so um i'm not looking
for an effortless approach
there's no such thing so tony uh one of
the critics actually that i once met
said yeah tony's techniques they were
great for about a year and a half and
then they wore off
what do you say to photo
it's real simple if you don't work out
you don't get you don't get a muscle
right so i always tell people this is
there's a daily practice like priming if
you don't do that if you get up and you
just have no discipline whatsoever you
get no value of anything your diets
don't work when you don't do them
exercise doesn't work when you don't do
them but mostly people have some
experiences that they want to shift and
once you shift those things your whole
life changes but life is constant growth
my life isn't here because i went to one
seminar one time and now my life is fit
for life i i work out i train my mind i
train my body it becomes a lifestyle
it's not just like you're depending upon
somebody else i'm not here to become
somebody's guru i'm not here to give
them a gift i'm here them to open up
their own gifts and that's really what
my work has been what would you tell the
startup entrepreneur who maybe is just
getting started or maybe still has a
full-time job and it feels like every
dollar that they're making they're just
trying to build their business at the
moment they haven't cashed out yet
should they be investing into the
business should they still be saving
someone put into the market what would
you tell that person i think you have to
put something outside your business
because what's the number one rule of
investing that even idiots understand
don't pull all your eggs in one basket
right and what did 90 of entrepreneurs
do because of the illusion of control
they go i'm going to put all my money in
my business don't get me wrong it's
still a great place for your money and
for your time with your energy but you
got to take a piece of what you earn and
you got to bet on some other
entrepreneurs and get outside yourself
specifically and if you look at you know
somebody like warren buffett will tell
you you know what he said my all my
wealth is a result of a couple things
some good genes and compound interest
and living in america so if all you do
is get compound interest on your side
the game changes you know if you take a
19 year old kid
that's got a little job and you say look
i want you it sounds like a lot but i
want you to put aside 300 a month but
let me show you why 300 bucks a month
set aside thrown in the market average
market return has been eight percent
it's been 10 over 100 years but most
recent you know 30 years 8
so let's say you get the average return
and it compounds
that kid who starts at 19 with 300 a
month can stop at 27.
he's only done it for eight years never
put another dime in
and he's only put in 24 or 28 000
but that'll grow to 1.8 million without
putting another diamond that's the power
of compounding 28 grand 1.8 million
if his best friend starts at 27 when he
quits and invests every single year all
the way to 65
and he puts in the same 300 a month he
puts in 140 grand and at that time he's
got 400 000 less money so it's not the
amount of money it's the amount of time
time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're gonna win and
you need to get in the game now not wait
till your business is successful i look
at control as a delusion right that's
the first thing it's your desire for the
illusion of control that's pushing you
what you want is certainty you want
certain you can avoid pain you want
certain you can have pleasure you want
certainly you can have a significant and
meaningful life we all want certainty
but uh learning ways to control what you
can control is wonderful but you can't
control most things what you can do is
influence them and so what i look at is
don't give myself the delusion i have
control because then i'll feel like i've
lost it at some point i never had
control i have influence i can influence
my kids i can't control them i can
influence myself i can influence what
happens to me financially can't control
it completely and so i think if you give
up the illusion of control that loosens
things up a little bit but i think the
second thing is to focus on what you can
control which is what what you think
feel and what you do
and if i focus on the things i can
control i want to feel better i mean all
the research shows
that human beings when they feel out of
control freak out inside and the more
they feel they're in control the greater
their self-esteem the way to have that
additional control is to say okay what i
can control is what i do within the
seasons you can say i don't like gravity
and step off the side here but you're
going to pay the price there are certain
things that are outside your control but
you can use gravity i fly a helicopter
an airplane because i understand the
dynamics of how to do that if you
understand the dynamics of the
marketplace you use the marketplace the
marketplace doesn't use you and that's
why i wrote unshakeable i want people to
have no more fear and when you start
understanding some of these statistics
like what's everybody afraid of a bear
market a bear market is when it you know
market cracks 20 percent or more
over the last 80 years they've happened
about every three to five years to give
you an idea later years more five years
well now we've gone the longest period
in history without one and yet people
are still afraid after every single bear
market we've had in the history of the
united states it's led immediately into
a bull market if you remember 2008 2009
50 drop in the next 12 months it was up
s p was up 69
it's almost 70 percent i can show you
every turn down so when you start seeing
that it's it's immutable it's like
winter comes but winter isn't forever
and winter is a great time to take
advantage because some people freeze to
death in winter other people ski and
snowboard and get by the fire well
winter is when things are on sale if
somebody said to you i got a 400 000
ferrari that you could buy for 70 000
you're probably grabbing a heartbeat but
if somebody takes you a stock that was
400 and 70 bucks you're like oh my god i
can't do this you have to look at the
cycles of history and when you do it you
become unshakable and more importantly
you become wealthy
[Applause]
the very first thing i do when i wake up
in the morning is i want to get my head
right i do this thing called priming now
some people get up in the morning and
they meditate and i think meditation is
wonderful but i haven't met many people
that can not think thoughts this is a
different outcome this is about priming
yourself it's about putting yourself in
the state where your mind and body will
respond accordingly we'll do three steps
it's really simple over 10 minutes so
why don't you sit down and i'll guide
you through it so just get really
comfortable you want to be sitting up is
that back enough for you to be able to
relax yeah good okay cool and then the
first thing you're going to do is your
hands are going to come up as you take
the breath in and then you're going to
explode out the nose down
explosive that's it
good
that's it keep going two more
good now relax keep your eyes closed
have your hands open if you would on
your lap face up like that
just feel whatever you feel
just take it in and you don't have to
respond to me anymore you just enjoy it
and take it in
and now just let your body relax deeply
and i'd like you to
begin to think of a moment in your life
you could feel
really grateful for if you wanted to
it could be something little rich or it
could be something big it doesn't matter
it could be from your childhood or this
week it doesn't matter do your best to
remember it and then
step into it as if you were there kind
of like stepping into your body and
seeing what you saw then through your
own eyes hearing what you heard then
feeling what you felt then
savor it
maximize that sense of appreciation or
enjoyment or gratitude
enjoy it
feel it
fill up with it
and now we're going to shift to the last
piece really simple all you're going to
do is focus on three things one at a
time that you want to accomplish three
things you want to achieve
live it and feel it and experience it
how was that
yeah what'd you feel
yeah there's two worlds to master the
external world in the internal world
they both have to be mastered but if you
master the external world you know
a la you know robin williams but you
don't master the internal world there's
a big price this is the one to master
first and so i start my day by making
that so i have this base to do it i'm
going to live from gratitude today i'm
going to live from blessing you know i
want to be a blessing in people's life
today i'm going to get stronger today
and i'm going to achieve what i'm here
committed to do and the whole thing you
know we did that one in a little less
than 10 minutes to give you an idea
why is lebron james who he is it's not
because he's lucky in other words say
you know he's lucky
he might have certain physical factors
or michael jordan i remember i
interviewed him years ago
and i said what makes you the best in
the world is it skill is it talent is it
ability is it background is it training
and he was so awesome he said tony i can
tell you the truth it won't sound like
hyperbole or false modesty he said i
didn't even make the high school
basketball team my sophomore year i was
cut
he said what it is is every day i demand
more for myself than anybody else could
possibly expect i don't compete with
other people i compete with what i'm
capable of and it's just like that kind
of standard is inspiring if you had a
billion dollars
but the habitual emotions you go back to
are frustrated and pissed off
then your life is called frustrated and
pissed off it doesn't matter how much
money you have write this down please
the quality of my life is the quality of
my habitual emotions
the quality of my entire life
is nothing but the quality of my
habitual emotions whatever
habits of emotion wherever my emotional
home is i will find a way to get back
there and until i change that i'm gonna
have a problem
how many of you see people in some part
of the world
in my country for example you'll see
this in the middle of america where
there's certain places they have
cyclones all the time or maybe down in
new orleans or places where every few
years you get a huge storm that wipes
out everybody right on the coast there
but then two years later it happens
again they rebuild it happens again how
many have ever thought to yourself why
don't these people move
and why don't they move guys
because it's what their condition they
call that home i don't want to leave my
home it's what i know
it's easy to see when it's somebody else
and it's physical it's harder to see
when it's yourself and it's emotional
because we have an emotional home some
of you grew up in a really tough
environment i did too pretty brutal
environment very painful environment
part of i am who i am is because i
didn't want to suffer and how to find
answers and because i suffered so much i
don't want you to ever suffer if i can
do anything about it i can't control it
but i can help massively
but it's only because i suffered so much
don't want anybody else to
but think about it
most people suffer even when they're
successful
listen
if you're successful and you're not
fulfilled
that's the ultimate failure if you've
got people that love you and you're not
feeling joyous and alive
something's wrong and you know what it
is you got an old home you're used to
maybe the home you're used to is not a
very happy home it's a home of worry a
home of frustration home of anger a home
of feeling everything is unjust and so
you find a way to get back home using
whatever the environment you can use
[Music]
how many of you know somebody who's
always pissed off about something
how many of you know somebody
who is always worried
how many of you know someone
who's not really funny
that they think they are
and they crack themselves up telling
stupid jokes how many know something
like this who cracks themselves up and
they laugh so much that even though it's
not funny you find yourself laughing too
these people have different emotional
homes some people's home is anger
they'll always find something to be
angry about
it's what they're used to
it's their conditioning so even when the
storm comes in and messes up their life
they go right back to that same
wouldn't it be nice to upgrade your home
your emotional home where you live
what if you could live every day with a
vast majority of the emotions you had
were
joy
and gratitude and love and appreciation
even in the middle of covet even when
somebody does something unjust
compassion
playfulness
what would that feel like if you were in
those states every day
90 95 percent of the time when you
weren't you got out of it quick
you can make that change this weekend
and i'm not exaggerating an ounce i'm
not saying you're gonna be perfect and
never have a negative feeling because
negative feelings are sometimes a signal
to make us change but most people are
negative ceiling and they just hang on
to it keep living with it find other
things to be negative about
they will never give you what you want
the money won't do it the
acknowledgement of others won't do it
everything you think will do it will not
do only one thing will do it you drawing
a line in the santa making the most
important decision of your life that
you're gonna live in a beautiful state
no matter what
because life is too short
to suffer
we have a choice listen to me
pain is sometimes part of life but
suffering is a choice
but for most of us not a choice because
we have the habit of suffering being
stressed being worried being frustrated
being pissed off
and because we're wired that way
that's the muscle we built
but if we rebuild our home here so it's
even more magnificent then you can have
the life that you desire and deserve and
you do it one weekend only if you give
your all and push enough energy out
while you're doing it while you're
learning
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible motivation from brendan
burchard check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you haven't had their training you
don't have the degree you don't have the
experience you don't have the background
you don't have the social following you
don't have the environment you don't
have the money you don't have the bank
account you don't have the credit you
don't handle that